on
[Musique]
un clip aux allures de courts métrages
le dard en mauve c'est le tout nouveau
titre de la chanteuse louise un message
percutant avec pour objectif de casser
les codes
c'est un peu l'histoire d'une jeune
femme qui a décidé d'inverser les rôles
vis-à-vis des hommes qui sont un peu à
la conquête de nombreuses demoiselles et
aussi on a on a vraiment voulu innover
puisque pour ce clip j'ai travaillé avec
un réalisateur parisien qui s'appelle
florian lui aussi et qu'il y a un regard
cinématographique réel dans ses oeuvres
et du coup on est parti vraiment sur
quelque chose qui ressemble plus à un
court métrage qu'un clip pour moi
vraiment le message en fait il va t'en
passer par les paroles que par
l'histoire parce que ça a été vraiment
un scénario que moi j'ai écrit et qu'il
a vraiment retranscrit exactement à la
perfection son empreinte musicale
l'électro pop dance un genre aux reflets
de son dynamisme naturel pour celle qui
s'est longtemps cherchée musicalement
c'est vraiment une musique qui me
ressemble et ça me permet de permettre
aux gens de s'amuser tout en véhiculant
les messages que moi j'ai envie de
véhiculer vianney tête la sortie de son
titre est prévue le 21 juin jour de la
fête de la musique etc mais l'artiste ne
compte pas s'arrêter là
prochaine étape le 25 septembre avec la
sortie d'un ep talent lors du premier
festival lgbt cuit ya plus réunionnais
pareil d'appareils
[Musique]
s'ils croient encore